you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
setting sail for antarctica we speak to
one of a team of scientists heading to
thwaite glacier to study the impact of
climate change
hotter than the sun and fossil fuel free
could nuclear fusion hold the answer to
a future of renewable energy
and finding a solution to help farmers
stop burning leftover straw in india
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
now a research mission to understand
more about the impact of climate change
on one of the most unstable glaciers in
antarctica is undergoing final
preparations before launching tomorrow a
team of 32 scientists will travel to
thwaites glacier in order to study its
impact on global sea level rises
while the ice melt draining from fruits
into the amundsen sea already accounts
for four percent of rising global sea
levels
warm ocean water is getting underneath
the glacier weakening and melting the
ice shelf putting it at risk of collapse
now scientists fear that if the thwaites
glacier were to melt entirely sea levels
could rise by as much as 60 centimeters
now the impact of this would be felt
around the world including in the uk
well professor anna vulin from the
university of gothenburg will be on that
mission and i spoke to her earlier from
punta arenas in chile and started by
asking her what she'll be looking out
for in this expedition
we are looking at
how the ocean influences the glacier
trades
glacier
we have seen warm ocean currents that
move in underneath this giant mass of
ice and we are this year going to study
the details of that interaction how much
melt do they induce and what processes
are going on
so how will you carry out your
investigations i understand that you're
going to use robots and also seals are
going to help you that's right this is a
super exciting
um cruise we have a range of different
robots on board and we will also catch
scenes that will be instrumented when
when the seals are caught we glue a
small
sensor to their hands and that measures
temperature and salinity and they carry
that for a bit less than a year until
the seams
mold and then it falls off when they
lose their fur
we also have a
fleet of different sized
robotics on board we have a number of
small gliders that will be deployed at
the start of the cruise and they will
continue to measure continuously
throughout the cruise while the ship
does other things
and
they transmit data via satellite back
home and they are piloted by the
university of istanbul in uk
and
they will be out until we have
or on the way back home and then we will
collect them with us
well yes and how important then is the
traits gracia for understanding climate
change
that is part of the answer that we are
looking for
suede's glacier has um
it has a lot of eyes
contained in it and the question is what
happens to this ice in the future
and the truth is that we know very
little about that we are
worrying that it might
release a lot of ice into the ocean at a
high rate and that would if so that
would influence future sea level rise
but um we since this hasn't happened yet
before we have models that describe what
could potentially happen but they have
not yet been calibrated with a real
event so to say
and right now is a particularly
interesting time to go there because we
have seen signs that the ice shelf which
is the floating part
of the glacier is showing signs to
breaking up right now this fall large
cracks have appeared
on it and it seems to be quite unstable
at the moment so we are
very glad that we happen to be there to
go there in such a
time when it actually seems to happen so
we will record everything that goes on
and this will help the
models in the future
and when do you set sail are you excited
about this expedition
oh
yes we are very excited we are
a little bit delayed but we have also
been in quarantine for nearly one month
in order to make this so every single
person on board is so eager to get going
and we hope to get going tomorrow
well good luck with it and we'll be
fascinated to see your findings
professor anna vulin thanks very much
indeed
thank you very much
in today's other climate news more than
one in four new cars sold in the uk in
december were electric according to
figures from new automotive pure
electric cars outsold hybrid models for
the first time on record while the
market share of petrol cars fell below
50 percent
well those figures come as mercedes benz
says it's designed an electric car
that's capable of traveling more than
600 miles on a single charge the vision
eqx design prototype is expected to form
the basis of a new vehicle going on sale
in 2024 or 2025.
currently most electric vehicles can
travel just under 200 miles before they
need recharging
officials in california are imposing new
drought rules across the state in an
effort to prevent water waste residents
will be banned from washing their cars
watering their lawns for 48 hours after
a rainstorm or letting sprinklers run
onto the path
percent of california was in extreme or
exceptional drought conditions in
mid-december and forecasters expect
drier than average conditions in the
first three months of this year
in australia a marine heat wave is
causing ocean temperatures to rise to
levels not seen in nearly 80 years
satellite data appears to show sea
surface temperatures off the coast of
new south wales are three degrees
celsius above normal levels scientists
say marine heat waves have been
increasing in frequency and intensity
due to long-term global warming
and people in cornwall are using the
ancient practice of gleaning to tackle
food poverty and reduce greenhouse gas
emissions volunteers from the gleaning
cornwall network collect crops leftover
from harvest and deliver them to local
food banks community kitchens and
homeless centres the group salvaged
almost 50 000 tons of produce last year
that would otherwise have been left to
rot releasing methane into the
atmosphere
now nuclear fusion is often claimed to
be the next big solution to renewable
energy it doesn't use fossil fuels or
produce hazardous waste materials unlike
the nuclear fission process which powers
nuclear plants at the moment but despite
decades of research it's still a long
way from being used commercially
well now a reactor in china has set a
new record for sustained high
temperatures after running five times
hotter than the sun for more than 17
minutes according to state media
so is this an important step in making
nuclear fusion power a reality
well joining me now to explain more is
the chief executive of the uk atomic
energy authority ian chapman so in
chapman welcome to you so first of all
what is nuclear fusion and how does it
differ from nuclear fission
the confusion is happening right now at
the center of our sun and all of our
stars
and it's the process that happens when
you take very light elements typically
hydrogen types of hydrogen you force
them together
and that takes a huge amount of energy
to do to force them together but when
they do they release even more energy
and that's the the root source of pretty
much all of our power today is happening
in the center of our sun
what happens in fission conventional
nuclear we already have is more or less
the opposite you take heavy things
uranium plutonium and split them apart
and then by splitting them apart they
release energy so two nuclear processes
but at very different ends of the
spectrum
and so do you think that the news from
china is encouraging
look it's massively encouraging let me
try and put it in context i think you
need three ingredients to make fusion
reality you need to operate at high
performance produce a lot of fusion
power
actually here in the uk we have the
biggest and the best fusion device a
machine called jet
we hold the world record for fusion
energy released
and actually just before christmas we
were running experiments to try and
break our own world record so maybe in a
few weeks i can come back and tell you
how we got on with that so you've got to
run at high performance then you've got
to run continuously now we built jet
back in the 1980s and when we did that
the technology that we had meant that we
could only run for a few seconds
since then we've developed a way of
running almost continuously and that's
what's been demonstrated in china so you
need to run at high performance and
continuously now the chinese results are
a relatively low performance but they
show that you can do it in a continuous
way
then you need to bring those two things
together and do it at a price that the
market wants to buy so make it cheap and
make it affordable
and
the again the uk is is really in a in a
prominent position here because we're
we're um aiming to deliver a prototype
fusion power plant a machine that we
call step which will be one of the first
devices to put net fusion electricity
onto the grid actually produce net
output
and particularly what we're aiming to do
is to have a much lower cost than the
alternative approaches to fusion
well yes and yet despite that protest
there are some senior industry figures
that say that nuclear fusion isn't going
to be commercially viable
until as late as the 2060s or 70s and
given that we need climate action right
now isn't the vast amount of investment
that's needed better spent on renewables
well i think we should do everything the
the climate challenge is so existential
and so enormous and i don't think people
grasped the scale of the challenge that
you must do everything and as fast as
possible on all avenues
i'm personally convinced that fusion has
a hugely important role to play because
whatever we do you can maximize
renewables as much as possible they just
don't work in every jurisdiction you
know there are some places that don't
have a lot of wind and a lot of sun and
we need other ways continuous ways of
producing base load energy and fusion
must be an important part of that
mixture in the future so we just have to
do this
in chapman interesting to talk to you
thanks very much indeed
thank you
now parts of india are plunged into smog
every winter due to the controversial
practice of stubble burning in the
latest in our series of climate diaries
we're hearing how one company is working
to find alternatives to the practice
which is responsible for as much as 40
percent of new delhi's air pollution
double burning is a major issue across
india
and this practice leads to a lot of
environmental impact massive amount of
health
hazards for the population at large
we are deeply focused on providing a
solution set that can solve and
eradicate this problem once and for all
[Music]
tens of thousands of tons of other
harmful gases were also eliminated in
the process this program can easily be
sustained
by offering this as a free service to
farmers as long as we continue to
generate carbon credits
that can actually pay for this
successful transition the path for us is
now to to really champion this and get
everybody involved in this process uh so
that we can achieve
our mission to get to know zero
do stay tuned coming up here on the
daily climate show i'll be joined by
climate scientist dr ella gilbert and
the chief executive of climate group
helen clarkson to discuss the importance
of that expedition to antarctica and how
companies can do more to go green
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news now we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with
climate scientist dr ella gilbert and
chief executive of climate group helen
clarkson so a very good evening to both
of you nice to see you both
so first of all as we heard earlier a
team of scientists are setting off on a
voyage to thwaites glacier a vast ice
shelf on the edge of antarctica now for
years images of melting ice have been
central to our perception of global
warming and a key way that scientists
have measured the impact of the climate
crisis
so elf to you first of all why is this
expedition so important for climate
science
well the sweet glacier is a really
important and pivotal
glacier in the west antarctic and the
west antarctic has been warming very
rapidly in recent decades and scientists
are fairly concerned about this
particular part of antarctica because it
contains a huge amount of ice enough to
raise global sea levels by over three
meters if all the glaciers were to
collapse entirely and the thwaites
glacier is thought to perhaps be a kind
of keystone um glacier so if it
collapses or if it melts very rapidly
then that could drag in other ice from
the rest of the region um and as i think
in your segment mentioned
there's this ice shelf that holds back
the glacier that's starting to
potentially become a little bit
destabilized and if that starts to
happen on a much larger scale then we
might be starting to see much larger
contributions to sea level um in the
next decades to centuries
so helen this expedition clearly vital
in understanding what's happening and
also what the risks are
do expeditions like this fire up public
interest you think in the issue of
climate change and potentially
generate action
yeah i think it's interesting you know
the discourse has really moved on
climate change in the last few years i
think if you think back i think five-ish
years or so ago
very much in the public mind climate
change was polar bears floating around
looking you know tragic on ice
blocks as you know sort of alluded to
that at the beginning and actually
things have really really moved on i
think now when people think about
climate change visually they probably
land more on on wildfires images like
that and i think some of the things that
have shifted have been around the public
discourse particularly the
student strikes and the school kids
saying what are you actually doing about
climate change and asking to hear more
about solutions and so i think we hear a
lot more now
less about prove to me this is happening
and more about what are you doing about
it so i think this can really trigger
public interest we see that with you
know david attenborough's programs and
people being really interested in in the
natural world but i think what people
will also want to know is okay how does
this relate back to me what's happening
about climate so the more we can talk
about why
this is necessary to advance our
understanding of climate as opposed to
you know we're just showing you more
sort of tragic pictures i think that's
really critical
ella do you think that's right you're
nodding there i can see that because it
is you know it's a frightening thing for
people to hear isn't it when they hear
about a big glacier like this
potentially melting and sea levels
rising so communication is very
important i mean absolutely as a climate
scientist who deals in these sorts of
statistics as my day job i can
very fully sympathize with the kind of
fear and
discomfort that comes with hearing about
all of these dramatic and potentially
catastrophic changes to our environment
but i think communicating that there is
a solution that there are things that we
can do and that there are things that
are being done um is really important as
well so it's not all doom and gloom the
whole time because that is just the
potential and that's what we're fighting
against well that's right and helen of
course you work with governments and
companies all the time to help encourage
them to go green so do you feel that the
fear factor if you like of issues like
this turn people off or does it
galvanize people to make change quicker
i think it's a bit of both i think you
know i talked about the school strikes
earlier and i think we saw that make a
big difference in businesses where
people were literally going home and
being asked by their own children what
are you doing about that and you know
what's your role in this and i think we
really saw that make a difference and i
think things like this will uh will
continue to fuel that and give people
that inspiration
to do more
okay let's move on to our next topic
shall we because back in november the uk
hosted the cop 26 climate conference now
the extent of the summit's success or
failure is still being debated but one
thing that most people agree on is that
governments can't hit climate targets
without the help of corporations now
prince charles wrote this week of a
military style campaign to marshal the
strength of the global private sector
because it will take trillions not
billions to transform our current fossil
fuel-based economy to one that is
genuinely renewable and sustainable
so how should companies be going green
well helen you work with companies all
the time to help them go green what role
do you think the corporations as opposed
to government should play and do we need
this military style campaign
to marshal their strength as prince
charles is calling for
look he's right about the scale and the
speed and the urgency so i completely
agree on all of that and the amount of
capital that needs to be deployed i
don't really like the idea of this
military campaign i think that um people
do more and do better when they're
incentivized to do things and when
they're pushed and the idea of kind of
that you know we're taking that approach
i don't think is one that will work i
think we've seen the the private sector
do a lot over the last few years and
actually what we find works really well
is when you bring
business people and policy makers along
together so
our work at the climate group on
electric vehicles we work with companies
who've made like 100 commitment to renew
to electric vehicles and then we go and
talk to them and say well what's
stopping you doing and hitting that
commitment tomorrow
some of the things that they've told us
was lack of availability of vehicles
well that's partly because governments
were not being clear about when they
were going to phase out the combustion
engine so we then took that evidence to
policymakers and said look if you bring
the end date forward business is with
you and so when you can get the
government and the businesses aligned
actually that's when we find you really
get acceleration look at that mercedes
story earlier you know a couple of years
ago when i was working we've done all
this work with electric vehicles and you
could not get the automotive companies
in the room they didn't want to
go at the speed that they need to and
now you see that they're seeing as this
innovation challenge and things like
this are very exciting so cooperation
important ella what do you think i mean
governments are constantly being
scrutinized for whether they're meeting
their promises what about companies do
you think they're doing enough
well i think the fact of the matter is
that everybody across all sectors of the
economy and government and society need
to play their part and that includes
businesses it includes ngos it includes
individuals and it includes governments
ideally i think there should be less of
a focus on kind of technological
innovations you know the the shiny new
technology that's going to be the silver
bullet that saves us once and for all
but more focus needs to go on the
solutions we already have the kind of
unsexy ones you know insulating and
retrofitting homes or you know changing
upgrading public transport networks so
that they work for people and they
actually want to use them you know those
sorts of changes that are kind of
less easy to sell and less easy to
say that you as a company are getting
involved in rather than focusing so much
on the latest technological innovation i
think i would really like to see more
partnerships between different sectors
so whether that's government and
businesses teaming up to actually push
this forwards on all fronts but i think
you know any money that's being spent on
tackling the climate crisis is always
good
okay on that note we will leave it but
dr ella gilbert and helen clarkson thank
you both very much indeed nice to see
you both
so that's it from us for today tomorrow
i'm going to be joined by specialist in
global environmental politics at cardiff
university jen allen and the director of
anti-poverty charity warren want assad
raymond
thanks for watching see you next time
[Music]
you